[Applause]
let's talk about the Han Solo movie yeah
solo a Star Wars story as you probably
know is a movie about a young Han Solo
and his adventures with Chewie Chewbacca
Plus early encounters with Lando
Calrissian set prior to the events of
the original trilogy because he's young
now this is the second Star Wars
anthology film aka standalone film a
Star Wars story the first one being
wrote one a Star Wars story and it's
coming up fast may 25th yeah it's only 5
months after the release of the last
Jedi which is still in theaters so let's
back back back back it up and talk about
everything we know so far about solo a
Star Wars story so is back in 2013 it
was reported that Disney / lucasfilm
would begin developing standalone movies
that existed outside of the episodic
Skywalker saga what would eventually
become rogue one was announced in 2014
and then in July 2015 an untitled Han
Solo movie was announced with the
screenplay by Lawrence and his son John
Caston now if you didn't know Lawrence
Kasdan wrote for The Empire Strikes Back
Return of the Jedi and hey the force
awakens and the directors were announced
at the same time bill Lord and Chris
Miller they're essentially a comedy duo
they directed 21 Jump Street 20 to drum
Street and the lego movie so let's jump
to July 2016 we're moving along this
timeline kind of fast so we're at Star
Wars Celebration Europe I'm sitting
there in my seat nice and comfy and we
had known this for months
unofficially but it was there on the
last day of celebration that Alden
Ehrenreich was officially confirmed as
our young Han Solo they brought him out
on stage and this is where I completely
fell in love with the idea of Alden
Ehrenreich as Han Solo
I mean his mannerisms the way he was
speaking his hair and my favorite the
way he said Falken the coolest part of
that audition process was I went on the
Falcon it's it's it's pretty
unbelievable
I'm captain in the Millennium Falcon
just like how Han said first time but I
love that you said Falcon on stage
that's our celebration which is how I
[Laughter]
know but here's what we didn't know who
the heck is playing Lando Calrissian
well this was an awesome day it was
October 2016 it was a Friday I think
like maybe four or five in the afternoon
I'm packing up to leave for the day and
then Lucasfilm is like
lmao you're not leaving for the day
because we're gonna announce Lando right
now on a Friday afternoon great for the
media loves when this happens Donald
Glover Donald Glover Glover amazing
casting and let's round out some of the
other casting here that came out around
the same time we've got Woody Harrelson
reportedly playing a character named
Beckett maybe Tobias Beckett this is all
kind of speculation but Beckett was a
name that Woody Harrelson actually
dropped in an interview Emilia Clarke
has reportedly named Kyra
I've seen like nine different spellings
of this but she's brunette with bangs
Tandy Newton unknown character Phoebe
Waller bridge also unknown reportedly a
CG driven character and Michael K
Williams had originally been cast but he
was reportedly removed from the film the
final film after being unable to return
to set for pick ups which brings us to
the director shake-up they shot a heck
of a lot of the movie up until June 2017
when it was announced that Lord and
Miller were fired citing creative
differences president of Lucasfilm
Kathleen Kennedy said in a statement
quote Phil Lord and Christopher Miller
are talented filmmakers who have
assembled an incredible cast and crew
but it's become clear that we had
different creative visions on this film
and we've decided to part ways a new
director will be announced soon
Lorna Miller were also quoted in the
statement saying unfortunately our
vision and process weren't aligned with
our partners on this project we normally
aren't fans of the phrase creative
differences but for once this cliche is
true we are really proud of the amazing
and world-class work of our cast and
crew only two days later Ron Howard was
announced as the director who would take
the reins and steer this consolo ship
into
this is where I admittedly became pretty
doubtful of the Han Solo movie it just
seemed all over the place I mean they
didn't push back the release which we
thought they would and I'm a huge fan of
Lord Millar I love their work and I
wanted to see what they would have done
with the movie and their kind of comedic
style
Ron Howard just seemed like the complete
opposite of that and it seemed like this
whiplash in tone and didn't really know
what was happening there
however devil's advocate on myself
Ron Howard seemed to work overtime to
ease our minds he posted photos from set
seemingly as often as he could he even
added some unexpected legends characters
like tag and Bank who appear to be silly
comedic comics in the early 2000s and
with each passing day I got more and
more on board with Ron Howard's Han Solo
movie I'm in for it
so around this time he added some more
people to the cast we've got Paul
Bettany we've got Warwick Davis and Ron
Howard's brother Clint Howard filming
for the project wrapped in October 2017
and that's when Ron Howard announced the
official title solo a Star Wars story
I'm fine with it now let's talk about
the score the quick and dirty on Star
Wars scores all over the board is that
they're John Williams babies they're all
John Williams but not the standalone
movies rogue one was composed by Michael
Giacchino and Han Solo will be composed
by John Powell John Powell scored a ton
of movies How to Train Your Dragon the
United 93 or some good ones to start if
you kind of want to google them YouTube
and listen to him for a minute check
those out but however in December as in
a few weeks ago John Williams was giving
an interview to Variety where he said
that he would write the theme for Han
Solo while John Powell will write the
rest of the score so what can we see in
the Han Solo movie this is where I got
doubtful because I'd liked the idea that
Han Solo is this legend that may or may
not have lied his way into the Star Wars
universe lied his way into the rebellion
it's like oh you've never heard of the
Millennium Falcon this is the ship that
made the Kessel run in less than 12
parsecs was he lying about that probably
I mean I liked the idea that he could
have lied or embellished his way into
the Alderaan mission to get money and
then was reluctantly thrust into the
Star Wars and eventually became a war
hero
I mean I don't really need to see how
that happened but we are likely getting
the Kessel run and how Han Solo won the
Millennium Falcon from Lando which I
like I like that I would like to see
that because it seems like the Falcon
belongs to land over much of the film
we've seen that shot of the Wardrobe
that he has inside it's like this nice
pristine Falcon and then maybe Han gets
it and it's also rumored that Jabba the
Hutt will appear in the film it's clear
they have this long history when we
first hear of him or see him if you're
watching the special editions but I
don't know what are your hopes and
wishes for Solo a Star Wars story let us
know in the comments or you can hop on
Twitter where I'm a Jedi in the streets
but a sit in the tweets see you next
time may the force be with you